how often do we get these stories where
joe biden says something and the white
house panics and then retracts or pulls
back it tries to walk it back
that happens all the time joe biden must
be like sitting in his basement watching
you know reruns of who's the boss or
something just totally oblivious to
what's going on in the real world and
they bring him out they give the
teleprompter and that's why he's not
they don't want him answering questions
that's why there was a really funny
moment when he was talking to the press
they he had a list of the people he was
supposed to call in what order and then
he actually said something i can't
remember exactly what he said but one of
the journalists asked a different
question he was like i thought you were
going to ask about uh uh anyway
yeah because it was it's all it's all
pre-scripted it's all pre-written he has
what was it someone saw that he had like
a list of journalists or something or
their heads
he had cheat cards with their photos and
their names and their media
organizations and and the pre-scripted
questions that they were going to ask
him all of it it's it's it's a show it's
all entertainment yeah it's it's it's
hollywood for ugly people i want to tell
you my friends
the media works
it does i often say that this conflict
we're facing the culture war has to do
with the people who are paying attention
and know what's going on and people who
don't the people who only watch
mainstream media or cnn have no idea
what's going on i can sit here and have
very different opinions from you inez
but we agree on reality to a to a
greater extent and that's why we're
probably having a conversation people
like uh these these lefty individuals we
pulled up the twitter bias of say vosh
who's a leftist commentator he consumes
95 leftist sources yeah whereas most
people here on the show it's a it's a
balance of left and right i want to show
you this i saw this on uh on reddit
r political humor they wrote it finally
happened and then there's our good
friend jeff teardrick who got his uh who
rose to fame by responding to trump he's
a trump reply guy he tweeted it's
finally happened the family of raccoons
that live inside lauren bobert's head
have completely chewed through the wires
and he's quoting a tweet from lauren
bobert where she says it's almost the
end of 2021 and i've yet to see biden
mobilize true international load
depression like he promised what's the
holdup this is fascinating i tweeted
there accidentally mocking biden but
don't know enough to realize it this
jeff teardrit guy is think is saying
that the raccoons have chewed through
the wires in lauren bobert's head
because lauren bobert quoted joe biden
albeit lauren you were wrong it
shouldn't have shaped up the pressure
to pressure right get it right that's
what that's what joe biden said
and so i i actually i saw that it was on
reddit it was like the front page get
the thousands of comments of people
being like oh my god lauren bobert is so
dumb
and i was like lauren bobert quoted joe
biden and you're calling her dumb and
saying raccoons are eating her brain yo
that's what we think about joe biden
why won't they get it because the media
didn't tell them this so the craziest
thing is when you pull up this dude's
tweet and you actually look at people
are responding they're like she's crazy
i agree with bobert biden to be mobile
mobilizing all sorts of made up words
i'm trending for being stupid again all
of these tweets calling her insane crazy
an idiot a [ __ ] etc you only need to
replace lauren bobert's name with joe
biden because that's who she was mocking
for saying
to
true
and
also said batacaf care i don't know what
that is either
and then here's the best part on reddit
i'm scrolling through the comments and
i'm like did anyone point out she's
literally mocking biden and they don't
realize someone did they were like
someone said what is this supposed to be
i don't understand finally someone
responded and they said it's from this
video and they linked to a clip of joe
biden saying turn it on chapter pressure
and then all the responses turned into
to make fun of a man with a stutter like
that is just wrong and i'm like you know
what man there's tribalism and media
manipulation right there because these
people don't know i i you can see it
if they genuinely think biden is
sharpened with it and able to do this
job when the dude speaks gibberish and
if you point it out they think it's you
speaking gibberish this is why i have no
anticipation that these people will be
shamed or woken up
literally woken up by watching a child a
child be harassed by police they're
going to pivot and pivot and pivot until
they're dizzy and they literally don't
know which side is up and which side's
down or what's up and what you know
i i have no hope for these people i
really don't this is idiocracy but this
is idiocracy um
how do you call it i was going to say
exemplified uh but tenfold exploded
exploded uh
curated and and promoted by of course
the algorithms that that make people see
this and and spread this kind of larger
idiocracy to the general public so again
this is not a i would say a perfect uh
reflection of reality but this is the
crazy car crash examples of reality that
people stop and look at but at the end
of the day this is still a car crash and
to me not a representation of a lot of
people so there are a lot of you know
people totally ignorant not knowing
what's going on they don't listen to
them well the numbers back back you up
people are losing faith in all of these
institutions not starting with the media
where faith has been low for decades but
but in all of these institutions every
single poll shows that we are losing and
in some ways that's scary right because
we do need some kind of institutions um
you know so it's as a small c
conservative like that's that's when you
have revolutions that's why when you
have you know a total rejection of of
any kind of order so it's it's
necessarily i think a kind of dangerous
time but i think it's a good thing that
people are losing faith in institutions
that are lying to them um and and so i i
agree with you i think that there are a
lot more people who do not aren't
plugged into the capital and narrative
than it would appear
what what you what we get from this
evidence or i should say data
not not definitive it's data adding to
the fact that many of these people get
their news from memes yeah now look
certain memes can be funny and memes can
share information and memes are a
powerful thing but you don't only get
your news from memes but they do
they don't actually listen to joe biden
they don't listen to his speeches we do
that's how we know he fell down he fell
up those stairs that's how he know he
said batacaf karen shouldn't i shop at a
pressure it's how we know he himself
proclaimed let's go brandon
because we actually watch and listen to
what's going on in politics same thing
is true with donald trump when trump was
president they didn't watch him they
only got their news from memes and they
believe it and they voted on it and here
we are a country cannot run based on
ignorant people voting for policies
based on each other it's like the blind
leading the blind off a cliff how do you
solve for it i guess we do shows like
this we say hey guys share shows like
this share share these tweets explain to
people make a meme of this and then show
the clip of joe biden saying trinidadian
pressure those videos where here's
here's it's in my head i can see it
it's a video of joe biden going shoot it
on a shabbat of pressure chew it on a
shabbat a pressure
then it shows jeff teardrex's tweet and
plays the theme from curb your
enthusiasm wherever there you go you got
a meme right there and then people will
see it and be like wow they don't know
anything about the guy they voted for
well i don't think anyone did i i think
they just voted against donald trump i
think the corporate media kind of
brought him to the presidency while he
was hiding out in his basement wasn't
even campaigning wasn't even there
shaking hands with all the individuals
he was literally doing a really crappy
uh vlog videos from his basement so
truly this shows you the power of the
corporate media but i think a lot of
people are being disenfranchised by it
and and their relationship with big tech
social media i think is the thing that
is making a lot of people blind but i
think memes are a way of of combating it
i think memes are awesome i think
they're they're great they're also a
double-edged sword there there's a lot
of disinformation memes out there but
predominantly i think if it wasn't for
memes i think we would be dumbed down
even a lot more uh than if it wasn't for
me memes are good things like making the
videos that debunk this stuff but if
you're only getting your information
from from like a meme group or from
reddit right specifically where again
everything's carefully curated and and
they push a vision that they want you to
have um and again i i was going to talk
about the intelligence agencies and the
ties to them but i don't want to go off
that rant again but but i i think it's
fair to say you know you know this this
level of idiocracy i i think is is
promoted in such a way where it looks
like it's the norm i don't think it is
uh but but people believing that it is
the norm makes people more ignorant
makes people copy and mimic that
behavior because they want to fit into
what they're seeing online as what is
popular and that's the trick that's
being played on people i think i think
it's a paradox for
these
media outlets though because the the
stronger and more obviously they spin
the narrative the more their
institutional credibility collapses and
that is backed up by like survey after
survey after survey so like i mean
that's why shows like this probably get
more viewers than most cnn shows right
um they are going to
the more that they spin that narrative
the fewer people are going to find them
credible i mean i think that's why now
you're shifting so much to where social
media companies are deciding you know
what isn't and isn't permissible to post
i think that's a reaction to the success
of alternative media because so many
people are tuning out from the corporate
media narrative but that in itself shows
the weakness of of the current system so
you're saying we shouldn't be believe
cnn when they just named the ceo of
pfizer the ceo of the year
well i i luke i gotta criticize you i i
think it's fair to say he's the ceo of
the year i mean look at the profits
they're raking in to secure these kinds
of contracts with no liability yeah you
are a good ceo some people would say
he's making a killing uh
no no i just just let's be real i mean
is it is it of all the ceos who's
guaranteed the most money for their
company it's either going to be him
modern or johnson and johnson right
absolutely they're more billionaires
than any other industry out there there
you go
you might have to fact check me on this
if i recall the entire um intake of
money for the the music industry in the
country is 12 billion dollars a year
okay
pfizer for 2021 is going to rake in 32.5
billion for this year
wow that's a lot of power dude and
that's a lot but
if i tell you this
how would you guys feel how would you
feel if the government mandated people
watched him cast iro
we'd be loaded we'd be billionaires we
got 300 some odd million people how many
of 250 working working age adults is
that is it 250 million i think so there
should be more kids than that i guess
not okay so all of those people forced
to watch the show getting 250 million
views per night and all the government
has to do is point uh uh the long arm of
the law at them and threaten
imprisonment and then we get all the
free money that you look you'd be a
great ceo to force your product on
people right
absolutely that's what insurance health
insurance companies exactly exactly
under obamacare yep
pesky seat belts
insurance companies lobby to make us
have to wear seat belts so it lower
lowers their costs it just really does
i i don't know if they i don't know have
any specific examples of them actually
lobbying for that though but uh that's
what i was told back in chicago like
people were that's what i was told so it
must be true you know surely you read it
in a meme
yeah i love how donald trump would
always say something outrageous and then
be like when people were giving him a
look well that's what i was told
people are saying many people are saying
no when i was younger i was out people
are talking about the click it or ticket
stuff and what i was told was
that insurance companies lobbied so that
um when accidents because accidents are
going to happen no matter what insurance
companies got to pay out the medical but
if you if you lobby for seat belt laws
it does reduce the amount of overall
costs on the health care system new
hampshire is one of the few places in
the united states where there's no
mandatory seat belt loss and they have
some of the cheapest car insurance
out there in the nation
so there's just there's that but again
there's there's uh of course exceptions
to the rule there's also some i don't
know about uh sort of who lobbied for
what but there there are a couple sort
of out there studies that i can't
necessarily endorse because i just don't
know enough about the subject but i have
read a couple studies that show that
man mandating seat belts have made
people more reckless drivers people feel
safer they drive more recklessly
so
feedback loop i i cannot speak to the
veracity of that though thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm now
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you